you had this conversation you put on
yourself stack uh with Jordan uh Jordan
Peterson about cognitive inequality I
think it's titled wrestling with
cognitive inequality
this particular topic of
just IQ differences between groups why
is this
why is it so dangerous to talk about
why this particular topic
well it's like you're calling black
people inferior it's like you're saying
they're genetically inferior that's what
people are saying it's like you're
rationalizing the disparity of outcomes
by reference to the intrinsic
inferiority of black people if you if
you say cognitive ability matters
for social outcomes if you say cognitive
ability exists people really are
different in terms of their intellectual
functioning and if you say cognitive
ability differences are are substantial
between racially defined populations
the sum of that there is cognitive
ability it matters and it differs by
race is the conclusion that outcome
differences by race are in part due to
Natural differences between the
populations people find that to be
completely offensive and unacceptable so
that's what I think is going on
Can you steal me in that case that we
should be careful doing that kind of
research
so uh this has to do with research it's
like uh the Nazis used Nietzsche
in their propaganda
right is you can use white supremacists
could use conclusions
um cherry pick conclusions of studies to
uh to push their uh to push the agenda
can you still man the case that we
should be careful yeah I could do it at
three levels one is what do we mean by
cognitive ability so there's many
different kinds of intelligence a person
might say
how good are IQ tests at measuring other
kinds of human capacities that are
pertinent to success in life like
temperament like emotional intelligence
and so on so intelligence is not a
one-dimensional
thing measured by G the cognitive
psychologists talk about G the general
intelligence factor which is a
statistical construction it's a factor
analytic uh resolution of the
correlation across individuals in their
performance on a battery a different
kind of tests and they use that to to
define a general factor of intelligence
and a person could say that is a very
narrow view of what human mental
capacities actually are and that uh it's
much better to think about
multi-dimensional
measures of human mental functioning
rather than a single cognitive ability
measure a so-called IQ
which is a narrow construction that
doesn't capture all of the subtle Nuance
of human difference in functioning
functioning is not just the ability to
uh recite backwards a sequence of
numbers I say eight seven nine five
three two you say two three five seven
eight nine it's not just that
intelligence is a
complex
management of many different dimensions
of human performance including uh things
like being able to stick with a task and
and not give up things like being able
to discipline and control your impulses
so as to remain focused and so forth
that could be one dimension I could
start by questioning the very foundation
of the argument for racial differences
in uh cognitive ability by saying that
your measure of cognitive ability is uh
flawed I could go to a higher level I I
could say what we're really interested
in
is social outcomes and the question of
what factors influence social outcomes
extends well beyond mental ability to
many other things so here's an example
um visual Acuity how well do you see
you're not wearing glasses I am
visual acuity
varies between human beings some people
see better than other people do
visual Acuity can be measured I can put
you at the chart and you can can you
identify and read that bottom line in
small print or not so we can measure
visual Acuity and it varies between
human beings visual Acuity is partly
genetic
well I think that's undoubtedly true
we inherit genes that influence whether
or not we are nearsighted or farsighted
or as stigmatic or whatever
so visual Acuity differs between people
and can be measured and is under genetic
control on the other hand
corrective lenses
allow for us to level the playing field
between people who are differently
endowed in terms of visual acuity
likewise social outcomes are what we're
really interested in employment earnings
whether or not they're law abiding how
do they conduct themselves and their
families and so forth amongst
individuals yes social outcomes are
influenced by so-called cognitive
ability but they're influenced by many
other things as well
if they can if there are interventions
that can be undertaken in society that
level the playing field between people
who have different natural endowments of
cognitive ability the fact that people
or groups differ in cognitive ability
becomes less significant just like it's
less significant that people differ with
respect to how well they see when
corrective lenses allow for the leveling
of that playing field there are in fact
interventions educational interventions
Early Childhood interventions that have
been shown to level the playing field to
create better life outcomes for people
even if they happen to be in doubt with
low intelligence so a second level of
arguing against this whole program of
research on human differences and
intelligences to observe that yes human
beings and perhaps racially defined
groups May differ on the average in
intellectual endowment but their well
may be social interventions that level
the playing field whether it's in
education or an other kinds of
programmatic interventions especially
for the poor
a final level of argument is the one
that you alluded to which is that if you
talk like this you're going to encourage
a kind of politics which is very ugly
and it's best to frame the discussion in
ways that don't put emphasis on
racially defined natural differences
between populations uh that's a argument
that I am myself personally
uh conflicted about
on the one hand I think you know those
people are just stupid
it is uh racist okay
on the other hand I think
the the calculation we shouldn't do this
kind of research suppose I'm at the
National Science Foundation uh research
team submits a proposal The Proposal
proposes to undertake a study the study
would explore the extent to which
people and racial groups differ with
respect to their intellectual
performance and how that's influenced by
their genetic and environmental
interaction and I decide not to fund the
study based on the political calculation
that the subject is too sensitive and if
you explore that subject you might get
the wrong answer and if you get the
wrong answer the white supremacists will
be encouraged
well that is presuming before the
research is done that I know the outcome
of the research and that I can calculate
what the political consequence of the
research outcome is going to be
that's that's assuming the thing before
you even know what the thing actually is
it's a kind of omniscience it presumes
that you as the master of the universe
can tell people what it is that people
are being treated like children what it
is that they're capable of knowing and
what it is that they're not capable of
knowing it would be like someone saying
to Einstein I don't know about that
special relativity Theory you know it
could well lead to the development of
technologies that would allow nuclear
weapons or someone saying the
Oppenheimer who is uh physicist
overseeing the Manhattan Project where
the U.S developed the nuclear weapons
capacity don't carry out that project
because
uh the results of acquiring that
knowledge may be more than we can deal
with or someone's saying to someone
doing a biomedical research who's
interested in exploring uh the nature of
the human genome don't carry out that
experiment that cloning uh undertaking
whatever because the consequences could
be uh deleterious well the consequences
could be deleterious the consequences
could also be the Cure of cancer the
consequences could also be being able to
generate electric power without
producing carbon effluent uh so who are
you to tell me who you being the person
in the political position to control the
research
what the consequence of doing the
research is I I think I don't want to
seed that kind of power to politicians
over the course of of human inquiry
so yes I would want there to be
regulations governing the use of
biologically sensitive and potentially
dangerous uh pathogens in a lab in Wuhan
or anyplace else I would I would not
want to Simply leave that to
laissez-faire on the other hand I think
that the tendency to try to shut down
inquiry on behalf of supposed adverse
political consequences is the road to
ignorance and impoverishment at the end
of the day for humankind denying
ourselves the potential benefits of that
kind of inquiry I think we need to take
our chances within query rather than to
try to control it and I feel that way
about the exploration of human
intelligence as much as anything else so
you've asked me to Steel Man the case
against
research on IQ of the sort that Charles
Murray is famous for popularizing and
I've said a your measure of intelligence
is single dominant intentional and it
ought to be multi-dimensional I've said
B the consequences of people's differing
in intelligence depends not only on the
natural endowments of the people but
also on the environment and the
potential for intervening in the
environment environment through one or
another kind of instrument as the
metaphorical example of the use of
corrective lenses to level the playing
field between people with different
visual Acuity
indicates but finally I've said
yes research on racial differences in IQ
can foster
um uh political beliefs that we would
regard to be
um obnoxious
on the other hand to presume that what
we don't know yet and might find out
from the research is going to be harmful
is to assume a kind of presumption or of
knowing what the outcome of unknown
processes might be which we ought to be
very slow to embrace because if we had
done so in the past we wouldn't have
nuclear power there's a lot of things
that we wouldn't know I mean what were
people saying about Darwin and uh
exploration of the evolution and origin
of the species they were afraid that it
was going to in effect disprove the uh
religious based accounts of you know
what were they saying about Copernicus
and
et cetera et cetera so you know that was
a masterful
layering of uh quote wrestling with the
cognitive inequality he dragged in
nuclear research uh uh Copernicus Darwin
biomedical research with genetics even
covet and
um uh the lab leak I mean this that was
that like that was just fun to listen